Donald Trump has announced a new policy
for the coronavirus bailouts that is
exactly the type of so-called socialism
note that I used the word so-called that
he promised us multiple times now that
this country would never ever ever do
Trump announced it via Twitter of course
saying that quote starting early next
week at my order the United States will
be purchasing from our farmers ranchers
and specialty crop growers three billion
dollars worth of dairy meat and produce
for Food lines and kitchens farmers to
Family Food Box
great news for all there are so many
things here to talk about and to deal
with so first of all yeah if you have
not heard about this that we have food
lines here in the United States and
they're growing and they're huge all
right the number of people lining up at
food banks waiting hours outdoors in the
heat waiting to get food and also at
certain nonprofits and other
organizations that are doing these food
boxes either for free or heavily
discounted this is what people like
Trump often say you would only see in
socialist or communist countries but
it's happening here it's happening here
in the United States it's been happening
but it's happening even more acutely
because of coronavirus that's number one
these are the bread lines that Don jr.
and others decried and announced we
would never have this in the United
States just months ago they said it it's
here it's been here but now it's here
even more strongly number two one could
argue that this is even more than just a
socialist idea Trump is coming up with
I'm not going to call it communist but
certainly we could be talking about
state socialism the government will
become the buyer from people who raise
food manufacturer raised grow food they
are going to be the buyer the government
and they are going to be doing that to
keep the company afloat and they're
going to redistribute those resources to
people who cannot afford them or who
don't have food to eat now remember
Trump has said many times we're never
going
to be a socialist country here's one
example from the United Nations today I
repeat a message for the world that I
have delivered at home America will
never be a socialist country in the last
century socialism and communism killed
100 million people now of course I want
to be really clear I'm not telling you
that this policy is necessarily a bad
idea given where we are today obviously
preventing it would have been much
smarter I am NOT here to tell you that
we are now a socialist country I am also
not a socialist what I am Telling You is
that this alpha' pull yourself up by
your bootstraps
of ideology very quickly changes when
things get tough and this is exactly the
critique of capitalism that a social
democrat like me has been making for
years we had been listen of course
inequality has been huge wages have been
relatively stagnant for decades by a
whole bunch of measures two months ago
we had a solid economy again by the
measures that are typically used we can
argue whether it's thanks to Trump or
not I think mostly it's not thanks to
Trump but we had low unemployment we had
a high stock market we had a appropriate
inflation rate we had high consumer
confidence wages were ticking up despite
not not being anything too dramatic yes
of course too much poverty we had hunger
inequality I get it but compared to lots
of times past and many other countries
things were doing ok two months ago so
the lesson is look at how quickly we now
have 15 percent unemployment potentially
going to 20 percent and how quickly we
have explosive food lines that are hours
long and how quickly we have the
government buying food from farmers to
redistribute to people who can't afford
it this is not about we should be a
socialist country it's just a reminder
that the US has had socialism when it's
convenient for a long time when there
are calamities when you need to bail out
an industry with companies that are too
big to fail well you'll apply socialism
there need to spread the costs out of
fixing the environmental damage done by
industry socialize the clean up
capitalism for the profit socialism for
the cost if you have a virus that you
mishandle
leading to an even worse economic
implosion than we would otherwise have
had well just start buying food and
giving it to people in food lines so the
solution here is we should be dealing
with the fragility of the system in a
proactive way instead of reacting in
what is a completely impotent way that
is the problem and the point of social
democracy is you take capitalism but you
commit money to proactively insulating
the system from shocks and calamities
free market capitalism by its nature
doesn't do proactive it's just not in
there it's too expensive it's not
immediately beneficial true free-market
capitalism would not do the proactive
stuff that's why you need the regulatory
framework of social democracy and again
this is the type of stuff Trump said we
would never have here and he's doing it
and he's right to do it I'd that I want
to be clear it's the right it's one of
the right policies given what's going on
the logistical and crony istic elements
of it will of course be a disaster as
always is the case for Trump but the
point is their principles evaporate when
they have a situation like this to deal
with